BRENNAN CHAPMAN: So Moonbot is
a multi-platform storytelling
company.
A lot of the mediums we
use involve 3D animation.
Google Cloud Platform
allows us to augment
our local on-premise render farm
to make sure that we're always
able to render
whatever render load is
on our farm in an
efficient amount of time.
We worked on a project last
year called "Taking Flight."
A lot of the scenes involved a
lot of render time to compute.
So the cloud enabled us to
shrink the wait time that we
had to do on the compute.
And we could use both our local
compute capabilities as well as
the cloud to render everything
in a much shorter amount
of time, which thus
allowed our creative team
to produce better results.
As we take on new and
bigger challenges at Moonbot
it's really reassuring to know
that we have the Google Cloud
platform suite of
tools and services,
as well as partner
technologies such as Avere,
that can enable us to achieve
anything we can dream.